KAMALA HARRIS IS MOSTLY SILENT
AFTER BREAKING ABOUT HOPE ROLE
IN THE AFGHANISTAN WITHDRAWAL.
>> HE JUST MADE UP REALLY BIG
DECISION, AFGHANISTAN.
FREE UP THE LAST PERSON IN THE
ROOM.
>> AND YOU FEEL COMFORTABLE?
>> I DO.
HE IS SOMEONE WHO I HAVE SEEN
OVER AND OVER AGAIN DECISIONS
BASED ON WHAT HE TRULY BELIEVES
BASED ON HIS YEARS OF DOING THI
WORK, SETTING THESE ISSUES, AND
HE TRULY BELIEVES IT'S THE RIGH
THING TO DO.
>> THAT DOES THAT AGE WELL.
IT'S ONLY A COUPLE OF DAYS OLD
PAL --
>> ARE SERVICEMEMBERS PUT THEIR
LIVES ON THE LINEUP AFGHANISTAN
WE WILL ALWAYS BE GRATEFUL AND
PROUD FOR THE MILITARY
INVOLVEMENT.
IT'S THE RIGHT DECISION.
KENNEDY, IS THE KIND OF THE
STRONG MAN ARGUMENT?
IT'S A CONVINCING ARGUMENT TO
LEAVE AFGHANISTAN.
HOW BOTCHED IT WAS.
>> EVERYONE AGREES.
NO ONE THINK YOU SHOULD PUSH
YOUR DATA OFF A BRIDGE.
SHE IS WRONG ON EVERYTHING.
AND SHE IS SO NARCISSISTIC.
WHY DIDN'T SHE TAKE THE CALL AN
GO DOWN AND START CALLING FOR A
METERS?
SHE IS THE VICE PRESIDENT OF TH
UNITED STATES.
AND SHE CERTAINLY IS NOT TAKING
A LEADERSHIP ROLE HERE, WHICH I
ALSO NO SURPRISE.
>> DATA, WHAT IS REALLY GOING ON
.
WHAT IS GOING ON?
>> I FEEL LIKE SOMETHING IS
GOING ON.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT IS.
I SMELL SOME KIND OF THING AND
IT IS NOT GAS.
YOUR MEMBER AT THE BEGINNING OF
THE MINISTRATION, I WAS GOING T
CALL HIM THE PRIME MINISTER.
THEY HAD KAMALA HARRIS DO ALL
THESE WORLD LEADER CALLS.
SHE WAS MAKING THE RELATIONSHIP
AND BUILDING UP A PARTNERSHIP
WITH ALL THESE PEOPLE.
THEN AT THE BRIEFING TODAY YOU
FIND OUT THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN
HASN'T CALLED ANYONE.
WE JUST FOUND OUT AT THE
COMMERCIAL BREAK THAT THE WHITE
HOUSE IS JUST ALERTED THE WORLD
THAT AFTER THE BRIEFING,
BROTHERS OF THE PRESIDENT HAD
NOT SPOKEN TO ANY WORLD LEADERS
HE HAS NOW SPOKEN TO BORIS
JOHNSON AT THE UK.
I HAVE TO DO A MENTION THAT THE
WOMEN'S GROUPS AND HUMAN RIGHTS
GROUPS HAVE TO BE THINKING THAT
THEY COULD'VE EXPECTED MORE FRO
THE FIRST WOMAN VICE PRESIDENT,
AT LEAST MAYBE SAY SOMETHING.
>> A WOMAN OF COLOR, NO LESS.
A WOMAN OF COLOR AND THE FIRST
WOMAN VP, MOM.
>> WHICH ONE ARGUE PREFERRING TO
?
>> I ALWAYS GO TO ERIC OWEN I
WANT TO SPEAK ABOUT A WOMAN IN
LEADERSHIP ROLE BECAUSE IT IS
VERY EASY TO SAY, OH, THEY COME
UP AS NASTY WHERE OR THEY ARE
OVERBEARING.
>> THAT'S RIGHT, ALL MY CHILDREN
.
>> SHE WAS NAMED AFTER SENATOR
KANE.
HE GAVE HER HER FIRST EMMY.
>> I REALLY THINK SHE'S IN A
TOUGH SPOT.
AND I DON'T KNOW HOW COMPETENT
SHE IS IN THIS ROLE.
SHE WAS PRETTY GOOD AT THE
SENATE AND ID AT AN ATTORNEY
GENERAL, BUT I'M NOT SURE HOW
GOOD SHE IS AND IT'S A DIFFICUL
ROLE AND JOE BIDEN WAS A GREAT
VICE PRESIDENT.
KAMALA HARRIS HAS BEEN PRETTY
MEDIOCRE.
>> YOU'RE BEING QUITE DIPLOMATIC
.
JESSE, COULD IT BE THAT SHE'S
OUT OF THE PICTURE TO PRESERVE
HER BRAND?
LIKE SHE DOESN'T WANT HER
FINGERPRINTS ON THIS NOW?
SHE'S IN HIDING.
>> I HAVE TO CONSULT MY WIFE
BEFORE I TALK ABOUT WOMEN'S
ISSUES ON TELEVISION.
NOW THAT CLINTON HAS BECOME THE
LAUGHINGSTOCK THE JOB WAS WHEN
HE WAS VICE PRESIDENT, SO SHE
HAS THREE OPTIONS.
THIS IS THE LOYALTY TEST RIGHT
NOW.
NUMBER ONE OPTION, SHE CAN COME
OUT AND BE A GOOD VPN SAY IT WA
TRUMP'S FALL.
IT WAS THE AFGHAN ARMY FALL AND
SHE COULD REALLY SHOW THAT SHE
HAS JOE'S BACK.
NUMBER TWO, YOU LEAK.
YOU THINK THAT I HAD SOME
QUESTIONS ABOUT THIS EXECUTION
AND NO ONE LISTEN TO ME.
BABY MAYBE BABY UP AS A AS
SOMETHING.
AND YOU GET THAT OUT THERE, KIN
OF RISKY BECAUSE SHE JUST GO
SILENT.
SHE GOES SILENT FOR ABOUT A
MONTH AND THEN SHE DOES SOFTBAL
AND SHE GETS THE CAMERAS TO FIL
HER HUGGING AFGHAN WOMEN AS THE
ARRIVED AT THE TARMAC HERE IN
THE UNITED STATES.
THAT IS HER ONLY OPTION.
SHE EMBRACES THAT I SAVED YOUR
LIFE WOMAN AND THAT IS H